some people associate instant noodles
with broke college students but instant
ramen wasn't created for a bunch of
hungry 20 year olds the man who invented
them was much more ambitious he set out
to solve a hunger crisis in Japan after
World War two food shortages plagued
Japanese cities so the u.s. supplied
wheat flour and encouraged the Japanese
to make bread one man named Momofuku
Ando didn't understand why his people
would make bread instead of noodles
something that was already part of their
culture on dude decided to take matters
into his own hands and create a new
ramen made to last he spent a year
trying to figure out how to preserve the
noodles he needed a non perishable tasty
and easy recipe but it was a challenge
to maintain the robust flavors and
unique texture that most people were
accustomed to it wasn't until his wife
was making dinner one night and he threw
some noodles in a bowl of hot tempura
oil that he realized flash frying the
noodles was the answer he had been
looking for this method not only
dehydrated them it left small
perforations that allowed the noodles to
recut quickly and there you have it
instant ramen noodles became an instant
success undos products gained notoriety
when he introduced the packaged ramen in
the 1950s and later cup noodles in 1978
his company began selling upwards of 40
billion units every year and Momofuku
Ando became a culinary icon in Japan so
the next time you heat up a cup of
instant noodles remember you're slurping
down a little piece of history
[Music]
[Music]
silly-string that bright fun party and
an aerosol can was actually invented by
mistake believe it or not it was
supposed to help heal your broken bones
in 1972 Leonard a fish an inventor and
Robert C Cox a chemist were granted a US
patent for a fumble resinous composition
the two initially set out to create an
aerosol can that could spray an instant
cast on a broken leg or arm and the
invention worked but when it came to
packaging their discovery they tested
500 different types of nozzles through
their tests fish came upon one that
produced a string a string that shot 30
feet across the room inspired they
decided to turn their instant cast into
a toy after altering the formula to
produce a more colorful less sticky
string the pair set out to market their
product neither of them knew the first
thing about selling toys so they made an
appointment with whammo in California
but the meeting didn't go exactly as
planned
fish and [ __ ] sprayed the string all
over the office including on the person
they were meeting with and
unsurprisingly out they were asked to
leave the premises just one day later
fish received a telegram from where mo
asking him to send 24 cans for a market
test turns out that a trace of the silly
string was left on a lampshade in the
office and was later spotted by huevos
owners who themselves demanded a market
test immediately
two weeks later grandma signed a
contract to license the product now
known as silly shirt
[Music]
little treats there a rearview mirrors
staple protecting noses from offensive
odors all over the world but where do
they come from over 60 years ago a
scientist by the name of Julius Amon had
a chance encounter with a milkman that
changed the course of the air freshener
game forever it was in Watertown New
York a milkman was making the rounds
when he stopped to speak to Julius a
German Jewish chemist who fled the Nazis
and studied out buying tree aromas in
the forests of Canada said milkman began
venting to Julius about the stench that
spoiled milk left in his car and thus
the quest began to destroy bad car odors
Julius drew inspiration from the tree
aromas he studied by infusing their oils
onto paper in 1954 he filed a patent for
tree shaped paper infused with odor
destroying air perfumes Julius then
started producing the air fresheners out
of an empty auto shop and sending
samples to local gas stations the little
trees were a big hit and Julius
successfully created the first
automotive air freshener though the look
remains the same the scents are forever
changing now the little tree company has
over 60 cents and has sold over a
billion little trees worldwide
[Music]
I've been making this drink sounds so
attractive and desirable for all these
years do you recognize me
the kool-aid man oh yeah so I've had
several people say it's hard to picture
that that voice is actually coming from
you the human being
oh yeah I like the voice because they
don't know who I am
when I first auditioned I think they
wanted to get the flavor of the kool-aid
man that was already on the air when I'd
came in instead of making it oh so he's
gotta have a big deep voice so I just
start like this guy wants to be a oh
yeah cool and I tried to make their
voice you know just kind of roll around
gutturally in my throat oh yeah I can
remember those sessions up there three
hours of them just saying okay do it
again do it again do it again try it
again
how about lower more energy more this
more Barry White bigger bigger bigger
louder louder everything like wonder
what am I not doing that you're not
getting but you're telling me to use a
lot of high energy like David Lee Roth I
said the two don't mix David Lee Roth's
going oh yeah doesn't mix with Barry
White going oh yeah so you have to find
a happy balance
bottoms up
[Music]
liquid acid a sticky liquid that smells
like butt crack with hints of dead
animal so there are these guys Andrew
masters I make liquid ass Alan Whitman
liquid ass creator no head janitor we
make the world's best stink product and
they work here this is what we call the
ass factory they hated their jobs so
they followed their dreams and started a
successful prank product company
specializing in a really rancid fart
spray but they needed a name I said so
what we gonna name it and he's getting
ready to sit down he goes I don't know
look what I asked and I'm like that's it
[Music]
then something curious happens we're
making a product specifically for pranks
at first but then we start getting calls
from military people enter Stu Segal
this guy Stu ordered from us and I've
never met Stu
Dudley he's got a you know a pretty neat
business he really does
and he come up with idea to use it for
triage but the fact is that it goes from
Frank product a medical field is sort of
a sort of a jump it turns out there's a
secondary market for this stuff training
some of the most elite Armed Forces to
do their jobs we are a company those
replicates the environment of combat and
right now we're in a set that we built
for medical training basically before
this prank fart spray some of our best
troops and emergency medical committee
with the overwhelmingly horrid smells of
death and disembowelment that they would
probably encounter as part of their jobs
it's a very awful smell it's something
that just smells like liquid ass back to
these two jokers now we have a product
out there that's helping military
training which is uh it's great you know
you know not all heroes wear capes cakes
cookies and brownies no we're not going
to show you how to make them because
they can be made with ease thanks to
Betty Crocker who was born in 1921 in
Minnesota well kind of
[Music]
in 1921 the Washburn Crosby company now
known as General Mills ran a contest for
people to complete the puzzle for the
most coveted prize a pin cushion yes one
of your very own surprisingly a lot of
people wrote in to claim their prize but
with a little PS they wanted baking
advice so the customer service
department began to reply and to make
their tips seem more genuine they sign
their letters Betty Crocker Betty
because it was a cheery all around
American sounding name and Crocker after
a board member not being a real person
didn't stop Betty Crocker from having a
very successful radio show the Betty
Crocker cooking school of the air with a
different accent in every state but the
lies don't stop there let's talk about
that added ingredient the egg you don't
need to add a fresh egg to powdered cake
mix but science says it makes us feel
like we aren't cheating and were better
providers so thanks Betty Crocker for
making us all feel like we know how to
bake
[Music]
the creation of the potato chip is a
rather snarky surprising an
idiosyncratic story when french fries
made their way to America they soon
became a restaurant mainstay many
restaurants serve fries as their
signature dish believe it or not they
were once considered very hoity-toity in
1853 George Crum was a chef at the
moon's lake house in Saratoga Springs
New York their signature dish was none
other than moons fried potatoes or as
the aristocrats would say potatoes
served in the French Menna one day just
like any other a customer some believed
to have been Cornelius Vanderbilt
himself ordered fries upon being served
Cornelius scoffed and sent them back he
deemed the fries soggy and not crispy
enough this insanity continued a few
more times until Crum lost it I mean he
really lost it he fired back cutting the
potatoes paper-thin and frying them up
you see back in 1853 eating with your
hands was a major faux pas making crumbs
revenge even more diabolical by cutting
the potatoes paper-thin there would be
no way that Cornelius could use his fork
forcing him to use his hands crumbs plan
backfired and kind of as the patrons dug
in with both hands and loved them
Saratoga chips were born they became a
Saratoga dining staple soon thereafter
they took the world by storm Crum
himself even opened his own restaurant
with baskets of chips displayed on each
in every table
[Music]